marion cotillard dans de rouille et d'os
non
et qui sait bien
si la revente catherine frot dans les
saveurs du palais sacrement chou farci
au saumon écosse et 40 du val de loire
c'est bien quand les choses deviennent
de quelque part et pour le dessert un
saint-honoré jean marc emile aux skis
d'un camille rothau
c'est mon sac c'est corinne masero dans
louise wimmer bientôt 50 ans je veux tu
m'intéresses arrête louisiane merci pour
ta gentillesse mais j'ai pas besoin d'un
mec dans ma vie emmanuelle riva bon
amour je ne sais pas quoi
lo'jo viennent ce n'est pas nécessaire
j'ai pas besoin de commentaires sur mon
état est invité à seydou dans les adieux
à la reine raison qu'elles trouvaient
les mains pour convaincre ces mots je
les connais majesté ils sont tous les
livres que je vous lis avec ferveur et
9h
hélène vincent dans quelques heures de
printemps
ben tiens je vais prendre ce petit vent
ce gâteau mois
le césar de la meilleure actrice est
attribué à emmanuel riba brabois
elle joue le destin des pianos rythme
encore s'il est mâle ou dans l'os pour
partie paralysé pour ce rôle à mon cou a
indiqué pilar et risquant cesse de l'âge
du personnage a passé des essais leur
finalement retenu
rivas qu'il avait servi dans hiroshima
mon amour et qui faisait à ses yeux un
couple parfait alignement avec jean
louis trintignant
elle est nommée à l'oscar dimanche soir
et a remporté un bafta et l'européenne
film awards pour ce rôle là débute au
slogan 58 dans les grandes familles de
détenus de la patelière il est
actuellement à la fiche de tu honoreras
ta mère est amer de brigitte rouan avec
nicole garcia
j'ai toujours envie de le changer
quand je reçois la bonté des prix de
caumont dire je ne peux pas le concevoir
ce pour cette guerre possible de ne pas
le penser pour avec toute l'équipe du
film
ça m'est difficile de d'être tout seul
avec ça
cc c'est tellement cher tellement
précieux je regrette
j'aurais beaucoup aimé que jean louis
trintignant soit là que mes filles alan
que soit la fin j'ai fait j'ai travaillé
dans ce film avec une une très grande
passion
je dois dire et j'ai eu beaucoup de
chance à l'heure si de ma vie de
rencontrer une telle merveille
mais schalke un sujet qui nous qui nous
en qui nous concerne tous deux d'où je
pense le succès du film parce que c'est
très proche de nous tout cela de nous
tous vraiment ce soir nous sommes tous
ensemble c'est pour moi une grande
émotion c'est la première fois que je
suis reçue chez c'est monsieur césar et
je vous remercie tout le monde
je suis vraiment pas ce que nous faisons
un métier de partage je trouve que ce
métier c'est c'est l'éternel invitation
à la vie c'est une action de partage de
vie non une sorte de solidarité
c'est comme ça que je le vis moi quand
j'étais petit par exemple on avait des
chorales à l'école et j'adorais chanter
en chorale de tous ensemble voilà c'est
une espèce de peut-être faiblesse que
j'ai mais j'aime être avec les autres
très proche d'eux et puis ça me donne
une très grande émotion
j'ai envie de vous dire juste quelques
quelques mots de kleist amis ne néglige
pas de vivre car elles fuient les zones
est et le sud de la vigne ne nous
embrasera pas longtemps et je trouve que
c'est une très grande invitation à la
vie
ce film s'appelle amour c'est pas
l'amour c'est pas un amour ses amours
c'est comme s'il y avait une troisième
personne présente là c'est presque pour
moi c'est le nom d'une personne amour
je veux aussi sous soir donné toute ma
pensée affectueuse à maurice garrel avec
qui j'ai travaillé qui est un très grand
acteur et je ne veux pas l'oublier ce
soir - que jamais voilà je vous remercie
beaucoup
vous avez fait
nous parlons nous aider
il est il est plus lourd que moi